a sense of shock has replaced the
disorder in washington
the u.s capitol now heavily fortified
and surrounded by the national guard
the odd protester still attempting a
stand
feels tasteless in light of the tragic
events
i sought the reaction of donald trump's
supporters
and found little in the way of remorse
i'm actually really glad it happened
i think we can all agree i'm really glad
it needed to happen um
if antifa and blm people can go up and
burn down buildings in which we were not
burning down anything we were actually
very peaceful
trump told us to go there when we got
there there wasn't one cop standing out
front
they knew we were coming why didn't they
have it guarded all i can
say is i'm so disturbed what vice
president pence said
i didn't believe he was part of the deep
state i didn't want to believe it
and i'm broken the assault on congress
was harrowing for those inside
protesters completely outnumbering
police
law enforcement were ill-prepared and
amid the panic
ashley babbitt was shot a video emerging
of the u.s air force veteran shortly
before she died
one of her last tweets read nothing will
stop us
the storm is here
[Music]
republican delegate derek evans joined
rioters
in congress later deleting this video he
posted of himself
online police are now pouring over more
images of people of interest
the first charges made so far include
possession of firearms on capitol
grounds perhaps little surprise many now
don't want to be identified the cops let
we're letting people in so i mean i
don't know how you want to
how you really want to describe that
they were letting us in the building
literally
a lot of the messaging that we hear is
make america great again
do you think that this is the way to do
it is this a good look
um it might to some people it might not
be a good look but this is how
us americans came together to stand up
for our country period i mean we did
like i said it's not like we burnt the
city down among the serious questions
hanging over
america is just how could a mob storm
supposedly one of the most protected
buildings in the country
and just how much worse this could have
been had they been more heavily armed
with the inauguration less than two
weeks away the city is taking
no chances extending its state of
emergency
and deploying the national guard for the
next 30 days
donald trump has failed to condemn the
violent mob
who shocked america there's now a heavy
reliance on police
to ensure a peaceful transition of power